[Musique]
ce geste fumer une cigarette
vous ne pourrez plus le faire en toute
liberté monsieur jean conrad le ralph
nader français explique la décision que
vient de prendre le ministère de la
santé publique
un bon ministre après consultation
naturellement avec le gouvernement et
avec le ministre de l'environnement a
décidé la suppression de la licence que
constituait la possibilité de fumer dans
les lieux publics
désormais tous les français devront s'y
conformer
qu'entendez vous par les lieux publics
le l'expression même est assez clair
n'est ce pas tous les lieux où d'autres
personnes se trouvent en même temps que
vous ou vous seul fumée ou d'autres
personnes peuvent ne pas comment
dirais-je tolérer la fumée et a fortiori
ne pas subir la pollution que vous leur
infliger vous croyez vous que cette
mesure sera facile à faire appliquer
certainement pas chacun sait que le
français très individualiste qu'il croit
beaucoup à ses droits et plus assez de
voir mais nous pensons que la pollution
atteint un tel degré n'est ce pas que
tous les français comprendront que leurs
intérêts se trouve dans l'obéissance ou
disons aux conseils éclairés du
gouvernement on estime que 60 % des
français sont fumeurs petits ou gros or
une étude du royal college de londres
montre qu'à 35 ans un gros fumeur
environ deux paquets de cigarettes par
jour à 4 fois plus de chances de mourir
dans les dix ans à venir cas non fumeurs
ce fumeur trop souvent ils empoisonnent
le non fumeur
il n'aura plus le droit de le faire
l'interdiction de fumer dans tous les
lieux où se tiennent des réunions
professionnelles de plus de quatre
personnes
par exemple la conférence de rédaction
de 24 heures sur la deux l'interdiction
de fumer dans les ascenseurs d'immeubles
privés ou publics
interdiction de fumer dans les halls de
gare dans les couloirs du métro dans les
expositions interdiction de fumer dans
les magasins chez tous les commerçants
dans les cafés
aussi bien aux terrasses qu'à
l'intérieur
interdiction de fumer dans les jardins
publics
et puis et surtout dans la rue ce qui
provoque quelques réactions monsieur
qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette
interdiction de fumer dans les lieux
publics
or moi je trouve que c'est normal
d'abord je suis prof humeur et ça me
gêne énormément crainte chez quelqu'un
côté le moal
la porte s'ouvre la fenêtre j'ai tout le
temps la fumée dans les yeux comme par
hasard ça c'est une très bonne chose
j'ai appris ça ce matin et c'est très
bien si c'est une atteinte directe à la
liberté individuelle et je suis
absolument contre
j'ai envie de fumer je fais me l'avoir
tué oui mais vous ne pensez pas que ça
peut gêner les gens dans la rue dans la
rue on avait eu lieu au chalet voiture
encore une fois ce matin-là rateur oui
c'est la radio j'ai entendu parler de ça
effectivement c'était une bonne chose
car nous dans nos magasins moi j'ai une
petite boutique c'est vraiment intenable
dans les cafés et pourquoi
pour ne pas gêner les autres
consommateurs ce qui n'est pas acquis 17
du change décembre c'est une bonne chose
pourquoi parce que les hommes en général
ce sont pas très galant et ils nous
envoient des bouffées de fumée dans les
yeux et leur cigarette partout c'est
très déplaisant ne fut marathon plus ce
n'est pas l'avis de la régie française
des tabacs la production de la régie
française des tabacs ne sera pas affecté
par cette nouvelle loi car il est
évident qu'on ne pourra pas empêcher les
vrais fumeurs de fumer une cigarette
dans la rue et notre part nous avons
l'avantagé à la régie d'avoir un service
de recherche qui vient de mettre une
cigarette au point complètement
inoffensive et anti pollution qui ne
produira pas de fumer quand les
cigarettes à par intel sur le marché
haut dans six mois à peu près et nous
détruirons 1,6 est ce dur principe qui
est de dire pas de feu sans fumée
[Musique]